here's what would happen if you  swallowed gallium  at first your piece of gallium would  most likely be in a solid state it would  quickly melt once you put it in your  mouth you'd immediately notice a sour  metallic taste as the thick paste  sloshes around your mouth coating your  teeth and tongue and everything else  with its silver stain  after you struggled to get it down your  throat it would travel to your stomach  now if you just stopped here with this  tiny bit of gallium that you put in your  system  you'd be fine but any more than that and  the gallium would react with your  stomach acids and become lethal to you  it would also produce hydrogen gas  causing you to have extra farts and  flammable burps  in addition to all this you'd notice  severe chest pains excess fluid in your  lungs and you might not even be able to  move as the fumes can cause paralysis  unless you got immediate medical  attention  you'd most likely die  so please don't eat any because